what you do with your week off
oh just I you know I hung out at home
because the kids were in school but we
did spend a lot of it playing with this
my son who shows me everything new I
just wait for him to show it to me this
new app which some of you may have heard
of called my idol
it's so that's becoming a thing yeah
sort of becoming a thing yes it's this
app from China mm-hmm
and you you put your well it takes
forever to figure it out because it's in
Chinese yeah but you take a picture of
your face and then it superimposes your
face on to like a little animated avatar
of yourself and you can dress yourself
in different ways and put yourself in
videos and stuff but it was I mean it
was I don't know if everybody's aware
but I thought it would be funny you did
this with yourself yeah I did this yeah
well I mean you know okay that's how we
do most stuff all right let's take a
look ten years off can you buy me a lot
[Music]
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
watch hi home
[Applause]
that I know why hearing on your
dispensing illegal medication yeah out
of a jewel box yes point sure what is he
doing China yes well okay I'm glad that
you did that because that's the kind of
thing if my son showed that to me I
would never figure it out a million
years I don't you know ya know I figured
as much
so I I actually did it for you okay I
took a picture of you you take a picture
of me I'm on and exist because you don't
have to do it with a camera you can also
just take an existing picture and put it
in there right and although your hair
you have to pick your hair your hair
does not exist in China did you make
this up yeah I did they want to see I
have is the best that I could here's a
little montage right your mic
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
like a communist leather daddy yeah a
communist leather day yeah that should
be the new opening for our show
just for a week we should run that as
the open absolute
you